everything's about educating people
teaching them lessons it's like
you're going to an island where
everyone's going to [ __ ] and they go
well maybe some of them are racist who
cares yeah suck each other off my child
who's a seven-year-old we watch look
who's talking never seen the movie look
who's talking of course in the first
five minutes of look who's talking in
1989 with john travolta kirsty alley
first five minutes
somebody blows up they blow a load into
the into the uterus and then they got
the embryo falling down and the sperm
just gets in the egg and right away it's
[ __ ] it's jizz and then the first first
five minutes they have babies taught uh
you know the little babies in the you
know right who were born um and and uh
they have an indian baby and they just
give the baby who's you know talking in
a voiceover in indian accent
yeah i want to be reincarnated my
daughter's on the floor laughing her ass
hilarious i'm like but meanwhile then
they went woke on one of the last
pixar's and my kid [ __ ] hated it
right it's like just say what's funny
please